[Music]
[Applause]
We Make Way for Daniel Jeremiah Chargers
radio analyst and network analyst at NFL
Daniel your reaction when the Chargers
got Jim Harbaugh was
what uh was excitement I mean look I
think he brings excitement everywhere he
goes he's W everywhere he's gone um I
was I was in the driveway playing horse
with my son and my phone started blowing
up uh from all my friends that I grew up
with that are lifelong charger fans I
I'll tell you my dad uh who was grew up
in uh in Ohio and has been out here in
Southern California for 40 years has
been a huge charger fan he was very
excited on multiple levels uh that Jim
Harbaugh uh got that job so he was he's
been a lifelong Bucky fan and a longtime
charger fan so he literally had the best
day yesterday okay what is the team
getting with Jim Harbaugh well you're
getting a couple things obviously you're
getting identity his every team he he
coaches wherever he's been has been a
tough physical line of scrimmage team so
you're getting toughness um the other
thing that you're getting is you're
getting somebody who's going to get it
up and running and is going to establish
accountability early uh I remember going
up there to Stanford I was scouting at
that time when he got that job and I
remember in that press conference I
think somebody asked a question about
USC and and he wasn't uh there was no
difference there there was no oh you
know hey we're just going to build our
he was like let we're ready to go
against them right now and all of us
Scouts we laughed Dan we were like this
is he's crazy like does he know how bad
Stanford is does he know how hard it is
to get players into Stanford like we've
heard this for years for decades and the
guy went in there beat him the first
year what like 40 Point underdogs like
it you know people can think whatever
they want he brings energy enthusiasm
and the guy wins what is Harbaugh
getting with this roster with the the
Chargers what's he get him himself into
well look there it's not a perfect
roster but you've got a great
quarterback you've got a you know a
franchise left tackle you've got two
pass rushers that you know you got to
keep them healthy they got to figure out
what they want to do salary cap wise uh
Derwin James is a special player Keenan
Allen's still an elite receiver like
there's a lot of pieces in place there
um I would imagine he's going to want to
come in there and really kind of you
know put more resources into the offense
and defensive line uh they're going to
need tight ends I mean it's not a
oneyear fix with some of the holes there
to get it to to where he wants it to be
um but I you know look I I think Justin
Herbert is going to have less on his
plate which is going to be a good thing
you know when he had Andrew Luck I how
tempting would it have been for most
play callers to say we're going to throw
it 50 times a game this is the best
quarterback in college football and it's
not even close and he didn't do that he
ran the ball they were physical and they
asked Andrew Luck to kind of make those
handful of plays so I you know I don't
know if you were talking about the MVP
before I came on you know I don't know
if Herbert's going to throw for 5,000
yards with Jim Harbaugh but he's going
to be very efficient and he's going to
win that that's you know I don't know
how that gets you to MVPs but it's going
to get you a lot more success in the
playoffs well you got to be the MVP
comes from the first seed or the second
seed in your conference I mean you have
to be either the number one or number
two seed and if they get there and
Herbert's your quarterback and plays
well because I don't know if Jim treats
Justin Herbert the way he did JJ
McCarthy at Michigan cuz here's McCarthy
expected to be a firstr draft pick and
you watch that Penn State game they
didn't even ask him to do anything they
just ran the football the whole time can
you can you is the NFL now for Jim is it
the same when Jim was at San Francisco
can you still have the same kind of
philosophy I still think you can play
the way he played at San Francisco
provided you had what they had I mean
that that offensive line defensive line
were outstanding uh with San Francisco
that afforded him the luxury to play
that way very few teams have that I mean
I I was watching the the ners game last
week and you know I thought man they you
know I know that they ended up winning
that game and pry ended up making plays
late but I'm watching that game going
you know you can just turn around and
give it to mcaffrey and win this
particular football game and you know
they didn't they didn't choose to do
that but I still think they had a team
that could do that um I think that's the
goal that they'll want to get to that
point here and also being relevant in
Los Angeles because even though the
Chargers had a potential Marquee
quarterback great
uniforms they're you know down the depth
chart as far as must see TV or even must
attend Harbaugh is a reason like now all
of a sudden you know there there's
something there I don't know if it's
enough right now but Harbaugh having
Harbaugh's philosophy or culture there I
wonder what that does to the LA
Market I think it'll bring enthusiasm
it's a Winner's town I mean you've got a
win to draw any attention and it helps
to have some personality um and you know
when you go when you look at the Rams
and Sean McVey and and what he's brought
I mean he's an incredible incredible
coach who's brought consistent winning
and he has a personality about him too
Jim's different but I think you get a
lot of those same perks of guy who's
going to come in and win he's GNA stand
out because of who he is and how he
handles himself which I you know I think
is a chance to to make a dent in the
market it's you know there's a lot of
teams there you're competing with a lot
of different teams for eyeballs but
there's also a heck of a lot of people
there um so I think there is there is
room to see this thing grow as it goes
forward uh talking to Daniel Jeremiah
NFL network analyst also host of move
the sticks podcast with Rett Lewis and
Bucky Brooks have available wherever you
get your podcast who was the backup plan
if Harbaugh didn't go I I I would have
been shocked if it wasn't Harbaugh if it
would you know expect Vel would have
been the choice it just feels like they
needed to go get an established kind of
brand Pete Carol wouldn't have been on
their radar well you know I think look
as a coach absolutely in the in the area
it would have been a very popular move I
don't know where you know with the
difference in age between him and Vel um
I know Vel hasn't had the success that
Pete's had but he still has you know he
comes with with a culture and an
identity and has won a lot of games I
think that would have been my guess is
is what the fallback plan would have
been when do you start breaking down
quarterbacks for the NFL draft oh come
on Dan we're there man we're uh we're
yeah we're at that point so I've been
I've been doing a lot of I actually
watched a lot of JJ McCarthy yesterday
so um those top five guys I'm I'm pretty
pretty versed on okay how many backs do
you think will be taken in the first
round I would say three are going to go
in the first three picks I'd be shocked
if we don't go quarterback quarterback
quarterback um and then after that I
think you're going to get a guaranteed
fourth however people sort that out um I
think there's six candidates I'll say
there'll be five and one of them will go
to the second okay Michael penck might
slip here he would he would be he would
be the sixth for me you know when you
when you when you put those guys all
together I think there's a some the two
interesting debates to me in this I I
think most teams will have Caleb just
the talent is so is so off the charts um
they'll have him W I think there's going
to be a he a real good debate between
Drake May and Jaden Daniels that's going
to take us all the way to the draft and
I think that the next tier between JJ
McCarthy and bonick I think is going to
be a really interesting debate with all
the differences in age uh but experience
and different play Styles what was put
on their play those are going to be
fascinating discussions if the Bears
called you what would you say uh we're
taking Caleb
Williams okay look Dan Dan we'll answer
this question Justin Fields would you
argue is the fourth best quarterback in
that
division yeah assuming Kirk Cousins came
back he's the fourth quarterback yeah so
my my thing is look there's no there's
no such thing as a draft pick without
risk but I would say if you took Caleb
Williams you got to develop him put the
pieces in place and make it happen I
would say you go from having the fourth
best quarterback in the division to
having the most talented quarterback in
the division you've got to put it all
together it's not a finished product
there there's development but in terms
of talent Caleb Williams is more
talented than any of those other three
quarterbacks I'm cuur curious about
Justin fields that if I'm the Falcons
it's not going to cost me much would
that be somebody that but I don't know
if belich takes that job or whoever
takes that job but yeah where where's
Justin Fields going to end up here well
think that be my number one spot Atlanta
you know yeah I think it is and I I was
I I need to be careful make sure that I
don't um forget to say this too Justin's
one of the 32 best quarterbacks in the
NFL right now he's a starting caliber
quarterback who's gotten better uh
throughout his career but I think when
you stack him up in that division right
that didn't sound like a great
compliment there Dani well no I just I I
think that people say that you either
are the starting quarterback of the
Bears or you're going to be you know
you're going to get traded for a fifth
round pick and go be a backup somewhere
else like there's he there's teams that
don't have a quarterback as good as
Justin fields and there more than one
okay I think Atlanta would be a great
spot for him I think that young team and
just let him go you know you're playing
half your games indoors on Turf and
let's just go let's because I thought if
Arizona moved on from Kyler Murray that
would have been another place you I want
to take advantage of what I have bejan
Robinson you got a couple of good
receivers there and and taking over a
team that is underachieved I think it
but I don't even know if they're gonna
give it to
belich well just just try to imagine Dan
just just close your eyes and imagine
you had an ultra athletic quarterback in
Atlanta I mean what could that look like
we've never seen it before you know just
let your imagination go yeah a rightand
a right-handed athletic quarterback he
just looking in the mirror he's just
looking in the mirror the other hand uh
thanks for joining us appreciate you Dan
all right that's Daniel Jeremiah NFL
network analyst and he works for the
Chargers on radio as well well